voilà les n'a critiqué vilipendé est
donc en passe d'être supprimé la
confirmation est venue d' emmanuel
macron à quel moment et pour quelles
raisons c'est ont éloigné du projet
initial celui d'une école au service de
l'état et du public la suppression était
la seule solution d'ailleurs est ce
vraiment une suppression puisque les na
va être remplacé par un institut du
service public
comment ne pas retomber dans les mêmes
travers dans la formation de nos élites
en lente reçoit l'uniformité et cette
décision suffira-t-elle à restaurer la
confiance entre le peuple et ses élites
c'est avec toutes ces questions que nous
laisse ce film ena pourquoi tant de
haine
d'alix et tournon et emilie lanson et
pour approfondir à présent j'accueille
christian eckert bonjour bonjour
ministre du budget de 2014 à 2017 sous
la présidence de françois hollande vous
vous n'êtes pas énarque je le précise et
vous avez mené des réformes dans l'un
des ministères dont on dit parfois qu'il
est le plus rétif au changement
nathalie l'oiseau bonjour bonjour vous
êtes députée européenne groupe
renew est dû sur la lys et le m ancien
ministre en charge des affaires
européennes et aussi surtout sur le
sujet qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
ancienne directrice de l'école nationale
d'administration
c'était de 2012 à 2017 bonjour gaspard
ganzer vous dirigez actuellement une
agence de communication vous êtes
diplômé de l'ena promotion senghor où
vous avez croisé emmanuel macron
notamment vous avez été conseiller du
président françois hollande pour la
presse et à mes côtés éric ans au
bonjour bonjour et historien maître de
conférences à la sorbonne et vous vous
intéressez au pouvoir à cette relation
ambiguë que les français entretiennent
avec leurs élites et vous avez payé lui
publié tout récemment les élites
françaises des lumières au grand
confinement aux éditions passées composé
alors on vient de le voir dans le film
cette détestation de l'ena elle est
presque aussi ancienne que l'école
nathalie l'oiseau à ce qu'au fond vous
avez été surprise par cette annonce de
suppression pas vraiment à ce que le
président l'avait déjà annoncé qu'il
voulait
on a vu que l'ena non ça c'est la presse
qu'il avait dit et gaspard grandir en
parlera mieux que moi à la presse
parfois interprète des silences sans
forcément avoir toutes les informations
non une chose était certaine c'est qu'il
fallait aller plus loin parce qu'ils
avaient été faits tenté jusqu'ici
moi j'avais eu la chance qu'on le confie
les rênes d'une école dont je n'étais
pas ancien élève donc je n'avais ni
nostalgie ni rancune
j'avais essayé de faire tout ce que
j'avais pu à l'intérieur des murs de
cette école mais à l'évidence il fallait
pousser les murs il fallait trancher
dans le vif il fallait aller plus loin
et ça n'a rien d'étonnant
ça n'a rien d'étonnant adapter le
recrutement la formation et les
carrières des plus hauts responsables
d'une administration
je dirais qu'il faut le faire tout le
temps mais pourquoi est-ce qu'il a fallu
la supprimer cette école est ce que ça
peut pas se faire en réformant tout
simplement les réformes avec pas suffi
jusqu'à présent en tout cas il fallait
une volonté politique au plus haut
niveau
moi j'avais eu la chance que françois
hollande me fasse confiance et j'avais
eu la malchance qui n'aille pas plus
loin que ce que j'avais essayé de faire
mon interne il fallait aller plus loin
en restant ryckaert le film s'appelle
ena pourquoi tant de haine finalement
c'est cette suppression c'est la
victoire d'une forme de détestation faut
être dans la suppression de l'école ne
va pas régler tous les problèmes on y
reviendra
mais je crois que nos alliés l'oiseau a
quelques raisons
la question n'est pas de l'ena en tant
que tel la question est de ce qui se
passe en amont et en aval c'est là où il
faut réformer l'ena a été le symbole de
certains dysfonctionnements sur lesquels
on peut pointer par exemple la question
du recrutement et de la diversité
et puis des problèmes en aval
c'est-à-dire la question de la suite des
carrières et
ce qu'on peut appeler l'entre- soir est
en tout cas la détermination de
l'ensemble d'une carrière par ce qui
s'est passé dans l'école ou au moment de
la sortie de l'école je crois que ce
sont salées problème et c'est pas la
suppression de l'école qui va changer la
question de la la diversité de la
démocratisation
il ya eu deux mots forts dans la
création c'était démocratisation et
méritocratie je crois qu'il faut revenir
aux fondamentaux
mais c'est vrai que ça éric ans au que
d'un point de vue historique elle
n'intervient pas n'importe quand la
création de l'ena jean zay le général de
gaulle c'est un symbole qu'on supprime
la et même avant et même avant alors
permettez moi quand même de réagir en
disant que la défiance des élites et
l'état des français à l'égard des élites
et de l'êta remonte à très très loin
c'est ce que je montre dans mon livre
est me semble-t-il
lena était le bouc émissaire tout trouvé
puisqu'il incarne l'état et les élites
oui moi je défendrai aujourd'hui l'ena
je peux être là vaut un petit peu
discordante
les nas est un magnifique projet d'école
de la république alors dans le film on
vous montre jean zay il faut remonter
bien avant hippolyte carnot 1848 c'est
la fondation la première fondation de
l'ena et lorsque hippolyte carnot en
1877 voudra reformé l'ena il aura contre
lui des lobbies le bis de l'école libre
des sciences politiques par exemple le
lobbies des facultés de droit
l'école de la république l enass et la
lutte contre tout ces lobbies pour fait
pour faire triompher la méritocratie
républicaine alors effectivement il ya
eu des dévoiements est ce que pour
autant il fallait supprimer les nageurs
ne suis pas persuadé et le gaz par
gandhi à ce qu'il fallait un énarque
pour supprimer les n'a peut-être oui
parce que cette cité supplémentaires
mais le président de la république
n'avait pas besoin des traînards pour la
légitimité pour supprimer cette école ou
la faire évoluer il et prénom la
république
bénéficiant de l'onction du suffrage
universel ou qu'il était légitime à
aller dans cette direction
on sentait d'ailleurs depuis quelques
années le début du quinquennat
c'était sa volonté profonde et même s'il
ya eu des hésitations des
ralentissements liés aux crises
successives que nous avons vécu pendant
ce quinquennat il est finalement allé au
bout de sa volonté c'est une bonne chose
parce que l'ena a été malheureusement 2
le symbole d'un élitisme au sens le plus
négatif du terme et que peut-être il
fallait changer de nom de l'énorme pour
pouvoir réformer la la formation et de
recrutement des hauts fonctionnaires en
profondeur gasp à 20 heures je rappelle
que vous avez croisé emmanuel macron sur
les bancs de l'ena
déjà à l'époque vous pensiez avec lui
peut-être qu'il fallait au moins
réformer sinon peut être supprimé cette
école alors bon à nathalie oiseaux a
dirigé cette école et que donc elle sait
que les nerfs sont font même des petites
révoltes et des petites révolutions on a
vu dans le film hier dans la promotion
et il se trouve que ma promotion celle
d'emmanuel macron que la promotion
senghor a mené une petite guerre contre
la direction de l'époque pour demander
une réforme profonde de la scolarité
parce qu'on trouvait la scolarité
n'était pas adapté à ce que nous devions
attendre en termes de formation
intellectuelle et académique mais aussi
parce que le fonctionnement du concours
de sortie
le classement de sortie n'était pas
assez transparents et ça nous a conduits
à faire un certain nombre de
propositions mais aussi à demander
l'annulation du classement de sortie
d'ailleurs de quatre sorties a été
annulée oms a pas assez de nous des
grands révolutionnaires du type
printemps de prague
mais à l'époque déjà emmanuel macron
faisait partie de ceux qui participaient
à ce travail de réflexion sur l'avenir
de l'école la suppression de l'accès
direct aux grands corps de l'état
et puis la refondation de la formation
intellectuelle alors on va rentrer dans
le détail justement tout est question là
juste d'un nouveau gaspard ganzer on va
on entend beaucoup d'anciens élèves
voilà s'est exprimée contre la
suppression vous voilà en tant qu ancien
élève
il n'y a pas une forme de nostalgie
aussi non son tempérament mais moi je
suis ni clanique ni ni nostalgique
si cette école doit être supprimée
refonder repenser jeu ça ne me posera
aucun problème bien au contraire je
crois que il faut accepter le sens de
l'histoire les a été créé en 1945 a
rempli sa fonction comme ça a été très
bien montré dans votre documentaire
depuis les années 70 c'est la crise
économique l'ena se cherche
lena a été refondée réformer en
permanence nathalie oiseaux il ya
participé notamment une chose positive
qui ont été faites au cours des
dernières années
cependant on n'est pas allé assez - il
fallait qu'ils un gros coup de pied dans
la fourmilière qui se tenait depuis
l'extérieur et j'ai beau être énarque
et passés par cette école je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les n'a fait son temps et
qu'il faut refonder la formation des
hauts fonctionnaires
alors avant de revenir vraiment sur le
fond encore un commentaire politique je
voulais ce qu'on entend beaucoup aussi
leurs proches de populisme
voilà est-ce que emmanuel macron qui
avait annoncé cette suppression à la
salle issue de la crise des gilets
jaunes en tout cas pendant le grand
débat qui a suivi cette crise est ce
qu'ils ne cèdent pas en quelque sorte
nathalie d'oiseaux à la pression des
gilets jaunes
écoutez quand jean pierre chevènement
avec deux de ses comparses écrivent
l'énarchie dans les années 70 c'est très
bien montré dans le documentaire cède
pas à la pression des gilet jaune
ils se posent des questions légitimes et
ces questions elles sont
extraordinairement légitime est-ce qu'on
recrute les gens dont on a besoin avec
la diversité dont on a besoin est ce
qu'on sort du moule et est-ce qu'on leur
donne la formation qu'il faut et que
deviennent leurs carrières derrière
heureusement qu'ils se posent la
question
et heureusement qu'il y apporte une
réponse que n'aurait-on dit si
l'inspecteur des finances emmanuel
macron avait renoncé à toucher à l'ena
là je pense que les critiques auraient
été dans l'autre sens c'est le charme
d'un autre époque
vous voulez ajouter un mot j'ai enfin
très rapide jean pierre chevènement qui
a écrit sous pseudonyme de mandera en
1967 l'énarchie effectivement avec deux
de ses amis aujourd'hui défend les
narguer défendre l'institution l'a vu
d'ailleurs dans le livre donc ça c'est
ça va un peu dans l'autre sens le
deuxième élément c'est qu'on disait que
l'ena n'évoluez pas mais il se trouve
que j'ai formés à la sorbonne et à
sciences po beaucoup des énarques actuel
des jeunes qui sont à l'école ou qui
viennent dans d'en sortir et je trouve
qu'on revient avec cette jeune
génération à l'esprit france combattante
justement l'esprit de 1945
le service de l'état qu'on avait
peut-être perdu pendant ces années fric
les années 80 80 sont bien montrés là
aussi dans le film là c'est très très
net et malheureusement je trouve que
casser l'école à ce moment là c'est
quand même tout à fait dramatique c'est
à contre temps c'est à contretemps pour
et un troisième élément si vous me
permettez olivier ferrand jérôme salomon
ils ne sont pas énarque dans la france
et directeur de la santé il est bon ça
va bien de taper sur les énarques en
permanence donc non non non être aux
fonctionnaires et pas énarque et et et
les énarques on les trouve
exemple dans l'administration civile
dans le corps préfectoral dans le corps
diplomatique
il n'y a pas que les grands corps etc
encore c'est la botte mais faut penser à
tous les autres sénat et les énarques de
l'étranger également qui représente la
france
christian eckert sur ce reproche qui est
fait emmanuel macron de céder aux
sirènes du populisme
je crois que de temps en temps
l'action politique nécessite d'utiliser
des symboles chacun l'a fait dans son
rôle
moi je pense que la question est
effectivement de savoir si notre
administration est performante ou pas -
vous l'avez rappelé je n'ai pas je ne
suis pas énarque si j'ai fait quelques
études à l'école de la république et
dans d'autres domaines
mais j'ai été j'ai côtoyé vers si bien
sûr le gratin de l'énarchie telle
qu'elle est décrite et je dois dire très
honnêtement que ce sont des gens d'une
grande qualité d'une performance
remarquable 6 précise puisque vous êtes
socialiste christian eckert quelque
chose qui est bien rappeler dans le film
c'est que les énarques au moment de
l'alternance de 80 ils sont très utiles
aux socialistes qu'ils aient le pouvoir
mais sont même nécessaires je crois que
c'est françois hollande qui le rappelle
à un moment donné dans leurs reportages
jeu j'aime à donner un exemple
l'énarchie est d'ailleurs l'ensemble de
la citadelle bercy était contre le
prélèvement la source n'est pas le débat
aujourd'hui
mais ils étaient tous contre françois
hollande a dit sans d'ailleurs beaucoup
consulté
nous mettons en oeuvre le prélèvement la
source j'ai été personnellement très
favorable et bien après quelques jours
d'hésitation l'ensemble de
l'administration ni chef à plumes en
tête ont dit ah ben voilà le pouvoir
politique a pris une décision nous
sommes face à un défi et nous allons
tout faire pour y répondre pour réussir
cette transformation ce qui a été fait
gaspard grandir j'aimerais vous entendre
sur ce que disais à l'instant à la fois
et eric ans et les christian eckert au
fond est ce qu'avec
en supprimant l'ena on ne perd pas
justement une forme d' expertise qui
finalement nourrit la république depuis
70 ans
non parce que je pense qu'il y aura un
autre mécanisme de sélection et de
formation des hauts fonctionnaires
moi la seule chose qui m'aurait inquiété
c'est la suppression de toute école de
formation de des hauts fonctionnaires ou
la suppression d'un concours comme un
haut fonctionnaire vers le retour à la
situation qui a prédominé avant la
seconde guerre mondiale qui est très
bien racontée dans un documentaire dans
lequel il y avait en fait un système de
prébendes d'octroi de privilèges dans
lesquelles les gens se recruter entre de
façon très très endogamique lennar ça
reste un concours on peut considérer
qu'il ya pas assez de de mixité sociale
que les énarques sont passés
représentative de la cité française
c'est vrai c'est malheureusement aussi
le cas des normaliens des
polytechniciens d'aider des élèves des
élèves hec ou d'autres deux autres
grandes écoles mais ça reste un concours
on le dit assez peu mais c'est un
concours difficile c'est pas le c'est
pas le seul concours difficile on a bien
d'autres médecines polytechnique par
monsieur plein d'autres mais c'est très
difficile il faut travailler énormément
moi personnellement j'ai sué sang et eau
pour avoir ce qu'on peut lui beaucoup de
mal à l'avoir et je lui ai donc c'est
pour ça que je pense qu'il y aura de la
sélection toujours dans la nouvelle
école ni en revanche je rejoins vraiment
quelque chose que vient de dire qu'elle
inquiète au jeu plus vraiment ces
paroles puisque j'ai vécu à ma modeste
place de la réforme dont ils parlent et
je crois que c'est vrai sur la réforme
du prélèvement à la source et c'est vrai
sont pleins d'autres réformes
les énarques sont des fonctionnaires ce
sont des rouages au bout du compte
et quand il ya un pouvoir politique fort
qui assume ses convictions et qui donne
une direction
les énarques sont toujours là pour
mettre en oeuvre la décision qui
l'aurait qui leur est demandé de mettre
en oeuvre et c'est vraiment ça qui est
important il y avait une idée que mails
macro avaient avancé pendant la campagne
moi je trouvais très bonne qui était
l'idée de vraiment assumé le pouvoir de
nomination de faire une sorte de spoil
system à la française eh bien oui le
pouvoir politique doit pouvoir choisir
lé directeur na bisso soir allez
préférer les ambassadeurs sans aucun
état d'âme parce qu'ils sont là pour
appliquer la politique qui est voulu par
le pouvoir politique
alors c'est très intéressant gaspard
ganzer parce qu'on voit bien dans le
film il devrait vous montrer cet extrait
qui à la fois savoureux puis qui montre
très bien à quel moment il ya il
commence à y voir une bascule ses
serviteurs de l'état à un moment où
commence à sentir très à l'aise et à
chercher à conquérir le pouvoir on le
voit notamment dans cet extrait qui date
du 20e anniversaire de l'ena regarder
pour les enfants de l'école
un reportage montre que les élèves de
l'ena assume désormais sans rougir de
vouloir conquérir le pouvoir
deux jeunes loups aux dents longues
l'impression que les élèves de l'ena en
grande responsabilité dans la france des
droits que c'était quoi sert-elle
quelques voir la composition du dernier
gouvernement et en particulier regarder
l'origine de différents directeurs de
cabinet note moins qu'un petit aleph
d'alema il y à un idéaliste connais pas
il ya aussi un avis il est assez
longtemps des questions les novilladas
liberté en mettant le pouvoir l'argent
les succès personnel etc
le pouvoir serait sans doute passé voilà
nathalie l'oiseau là dessus l'école du
service public qui devient l'école du
pouvoir c'était inévitable
à écouter ces élèves-là de ce
documentaire ne ressens pas du tout aux
élèves que j'ai connus qui sont venus
vraiment se mettre au service de la
nation aux services de langue de bois
dont vous dites là non parce que je n'ai
pas de raison de défendre ou ne pas
défendre les élèves il se trouve que
j'ai beaucoup fréquenté les élèves de
l'école que j'ai dirigé pendant cinq ans
et c'est pas du tout ça que j'ai vu
c'est pas du tout ça que j'ai entendu
heureusement tous ne se ressemblaient
pas d'ailleurs c'est pas une école du
pouvoir c'est une école du devoir ou
c'est une école du service public et je
pense que le terme institut du service
public est plutôt assez bien choisi le
fait qu'il met au service dans la
nouvelle dénomination de cette école
c'est important c'est indispensable
bien sûr ça monte laisser la devise de
l'école servir sens à servir servir sans
s'intéresser très intéressant ça parce
que on a l'impression que c'est c'est le
problème de tout pouvoir de toute
bureaucratie harrigan soleil à un moment
où les hauts fonctionnaires se prennent
pour les hommes de pouvoir bien
évidemment et c'est tout le rôle du
politique de les ramener à leurs devoirs
à leur fonction a effectivement je crois
que gaspard get there et christian
eckert long très très bien dit c'est le
rôle du politique
si on permettait d'ajouter quelque chose
moi je crois qu'il faut laisser sa
chance à la réforme effectivement il ya
beaucoup de choses très positives dans
le rapport thiriez et j espère qu il est
là dernier donc qui a qui a remis un
rapport il ya quelques mois qui ruinent
réforme exactement et la déclaration du
président mcrory hier est fortement
inspirée semble aller dans le sens
justement du rapport thiriez donc moi je
ne jette pas la pierre de ce point de
vue ce qui m'inquiète un petit peu si
vous voulez on évoquait l'entrée à aller
n'a cessé ce fameux concours parce que
le concours encore une fois à la base il
est trés méritocratique et là on voit
bien que l'un des buts peut-être
démagogique
bon je ne jette pas la pierre là encore
au président c'est d'ouvrir socialement
l'école de l'entrée l'entrée la saison
d'entraîneur du concours d'entrée du
concours de sortie
le problème il est pas là le problème il
est dans l'école de la république on le
sait tout se joue beaucoup plus tôt
alors là il ya les réformes initiées par
le ministre jean michel blanquer que je
salue ici mais c'est là qu'il faut agir
quand vous avez 18 ou 19 ans mais tout
est joué on va pas on va pas faire
entrer quelqu'un à l'ena qui n'auraient
pas forcément les compétences égales de
quelqu'un qui va être écarté moi j'ai vu
des choses vous savez en faisant passer
les concours d'entrée à sciences po
terrible des jeunes qui nous disaient
mais voilà il y aller les autres voix et
et moi qui dont les parents ne parlent
pas français
peut-être que vous allez me refuse est
ce que j'ai un quart de point de moins
vous avez réduit le nombre d'entrées
avec ces concours parallèle on va
reparler évidemment la question du
recrutement de la diversité et lieu
l'uniformité d'un mot quand même sur
cette ressource reproche christian
eckert de la confiscation en quelque
sorte du pouvoir pas parce qu'on a
appelée l'énarchie c'est ma tendre le
dictionnaire vous l'avait expérimenté ça
vous
lorsque vous étiez à à bercy christian
kert tout à fait il est évident que les
fonctionnaires détiennent la formation
ne la font pas toujours remonté comme il
est convenu de dire au cabinet ou voir
même au ministre prenne la place des
politiques mais ils prennent la place
qu'on leur lance c'est là où il faut se
dire qu'un ministre doit pouvoir
évidemment choisir les membres de son
cabinet que il doit choisir des membres
de cabinets qui ont le même type de
compétences voire même plus de
compétences que les directeurs des
administrations centrales et qu' il doit
y avoir un travail continu de
vérification des changes de travail
entre le cabinet du ministre je et
l'administration se lève je cite souvent
l'exemple le début du mandat des manuels
maquereau ou hilla contingenté les bords
de cabinet de chacun de ses ministres et
particulièrement bercy jeu 7e
catastrophe
ça a été une catastrophe les burnout les
dysfonctionnements ça n'a pas fonctionné
mais emmanuel macron le savez sur rennes
confidente
quand emmanuel macron et ministre à
bercy il avait 25 membres de cabinets 25
si vous voulez je vous en donnerai la
liste lorsqu'il est devenu président il
a imposé un maximum de cinq ministres ou
secrétaires d'état de cinq membres de
camino secrétaires d'états le disent à
ses ministres c'est une erreur
fondamentale c'est ça qui donne le
pouvoir aux administrations
c'est la faiblesse de l'équipe troch
rapprocher au tour du ministre mais il
faut assumer d'avoir des équipes qui
dans la continuité gère l'administration
et puis pendant le temps du mandat
accompagne le pouvoir politique
peut-être un contrepoint de nathalie
l'oiseau sur ce point rapidement parce
qu'ils sont pas le coeur du sujet mais
je trouve que j'ai été directeur
d'administration centrale j'étais membre
de cabinet me sahel j'étais ministre
donc je crois que j'ai vu ça de
plusieurs
et je me suis un de chirac qui disait un
chef ça doit savoir j'ai fait un
ministre ça doit travailler avec ses
directeurs d'administration centrale et
si le directeur fait pas son boulot
s'il suit pas les consignes et ses mini
c'est parce qu'il veut sont en change
ministre on change de directeur mais se
réfugier derrière un cabinet en disant
il faut 25 personnes pour pouvoir passer
mes consignes moi j'ai été au cabinet ma
musique était un grand homme d'état qui
était alain juppé et je peux vous
assurer que tout ce petit ministère des
affaires étrangères qui est un micro
ministère au sein de l'état fonctionné à
plein parce qu'il y avait un ministre
qui savaient ce qu'ils voulaient qu'ils
écoutent et ses directeurs qui savaient
leur dire ses instructions à tout moment
un mot gaspard gander sur ce qui
apparaît aux yeux de beaucoup de
français comme une forme d'anomalie en
tout cas la preuve de cette endogamie
c'est que par exemple que edouard
philippe dans son dernier livre appelle
le carré magique c'est à dire le
président le premier ministre le
secrétaire général de l'elysée et le
directeur de cabinet du premier ministre
aujourd'hui comme sous edouard philippe
ce sont quatre énarque est ce qu'il n'ya
pas un problème de confusion des genres
là ça ne me choque pas du tout que ça ne
vous choque pas qu'on mette nom qu'on
mette au secrétariat général de l'elysée
ou away la direction de cabinet de
matignon des nerfs des gens qui
connaissent le fonctionnement des tâches
faux procès plutôt heureux après on peut
s'interroger plus généralement sur les
modalités de recrutement notre personnel
politique
on a eu effectivement plusieurs
présidents de la république qui sont
issus de l'ena plusieurs premiers
ministres
c'est ça de voir interrogé sur la
composition de test politique mais je ne
crois pas non plus que l'on soit
condamné à avoir que des énarques la
présence de la république ou à matignon
et ça a été une situation différente par
le passé il y en aura d'autres à la
suite je trouve que c'est bien qu'ils
aient plus de diversité aussi en la
matière faucon il faut qu'on avance sur
un certain nombre de reproches qui sont
faits à l'ena ce que j'appelle moi les
raisons de la disgrâce finalement et
notamment jeu qui a souvent été évoqué
ce sujet qu'est le pantouflage le fait
qu'on puisse faire des allers-retours
dans le prix j'ai quand on est énarque
et avoir en quelque sorte une forme de
sécurité de l'emploi puisque quand on a
un problème on revient dans son corps
d'origine
le film nous dit qu'en fait en tout cas
si on regarde bien les chiffres qui sont
donnés dans le
dans le film c'est un phénomène marginal
natel et l'oiseau saha génome est nul
très marginale et qui moi ne me choque
pas du tout je trouve qu'il ya déjà
beaucoup trop de silos dans notre
société
tout le monde a des préjugés sur tout le
monde les entreprises sur les nages et
de souvenirs assez amusant d'avoir fait
venir un patron du medef à l'ena mais en
lui disant vous venez pas une heure
faire une conférence vous venez une
journée pour essayer de comprendre ce
que c'est que cette école est ce que
seront ses élèves
et là aussi des préjugés ou une
méconnaissance du monde de l'entreprise
par l'administration
chacun pensant que l'autre c'est le
diable qu'il n'a rien compris les
alésiens ses seins à partir du moment où
cet encadré où il ya de la transparence
est aujourd'hui ce qui est quand même un
risque de conflit d'intérêts aujourd'hui
tout ça est vérifiée et tout ça est
beaucoup plus exigeante dans le dans le
passé mais c'est une aération dans les
deux sens arrêtons de passer notre tom
tourné le dos la difficulté aujourd'hui
elle est déjà dans les administrations
vous avez certains ministères vous avez
une domination du corps des mines ou de
corps issu de polytechnique qui ne
veulent pas voir arriver les énarques et
vice et versa ça nous tue ce je crois
déceler un désaccord c'est christian
eckert sur ce oui moi je crois que la
question des conflits d'intérêts une
question majeure
quelques progrès en matière de
surveillance mais il ya aussi beaucoup
d'exemples qui montrent que cette
surveillance a laissé beaucoup de trous
dans la raquette si j'ose m'exprimer
ainsi
moi je suis moins favorables ou question
d'aller retour je pense que notre
administration connaît moins mal le
monde réel
là encore une métaphore ce que que ce
que l'on dit alors je vous coupe reste
inquiète parce qu'il faut qu'on avance
sur un certain nombre de sujets mais
peut-être là-dessus gaspard candeur sur
sur la question de du pantouflage
rien n'est prévu dans la réforme
annoncée par emmanuel macron finalement
les allers retours pour avoir continué
sa vous ça vous choque ça vous voit non
pas du tout et et serait il serait mal
placé pour que ça me choque puisque
moi-même depuis quatre ans je suis en
disponibilité de la fonction publique et
je suis allé créer une entreprise et je
peux vous dire viendriez si jamais vous
avez un pépin si votre entreprise
on nous fait pas un mais faisait
faillite dans dans votre corps d'origine
non je ne reviendrai pas pour cette
raison si jamais j'ai chaud comme
entrepreneur je créerai une autre
entreprise
en revanche je si un jour on décide de
me confier une responsabilité dans une
administration centrale dans le corps
préfectoral je ne sais où et que la
france la république me retape sur
l'épaule en disant écoute gaspard on a
besoin de toi est ce que tu peux
conduire cette mission je serai ravi de
pouvoir le faire mais je ne reviendrais
simplement pour apporter quelque chose
pas pour me sauver moi même en revanche
je ça te fera peut-être un peu de ma
seule petite nuance avec l'historique
heures je pense que quand il ya beaucoup
de choses qui ont été faites en matière
de transparence de la vie publique je
peux vous dire que moi j'ai je suis
passé en commission de déontologie je
remplis des déclarations à l'achat tvp
du matin jusqu'au soir
grâce à françois hollande grâce à michel
sapin tout ça est quand même très
surveillée on a beaucoup progressé au
cours des dernières années
franchement on peut on peut s'inquiéter
de ce qui existait avant parce que
l'ipad lancé ça un système qui
fonctionne quand même assez bien même si
on peut toujours faire mieux
et puis l'autre point c'est que je pense
que les énarques ne savent pas ce que
c'est nathalie d'oiseaux ne prendra pas
mal j'espère que la vie en entreprise
moi j'ai découvert la vie en entreprise
en créant ma propre entreprise
j'ai découvert ce que était d'aller
chercher des clients de prendre des
risques personnels de mettre son argent
personnel dans la création d'une
entreprise et la création de valeur et
je peux vous dire qu'on apprend la
modestie quand on devient un petit
entrepreneur il faut parler d'un sujet
qui autour duquel on tourne depuis tout
à l'heure c'est celui des grands corps
peut-être drame ou d'avoir eric en saut
de quoi on parle quand on parle de ces
grands corps auquel si j'ai bien compris
la réforme on ne va pas toucher là non
plus un accès nous apparaît comme un
rappel historique sur les grands corps
ferait rapidement l'un des grands corps
pour les nommer c'est le conseil d'état
et la cour des comptes créé sous
napoléon 1
on fait actuellement le bicentenaire de
la mort de napoléon donc là on a des
masses de granit qui ont été créés à
cette époque là est un petit peu plus
tard sous la monarchie de juillet
l'inspection générale ce sont des
institutions très française et lorsqu'on
sort dans la botte de l'ena et bien on
se destine à c'est assez grand corps et
nathalie l'oiseau je disais si j'ai bien
compris la réforme on ne supprime pas
vous dit c'est pas tout à fait ça bah
c'est pas tout à fait ça parce que il ya
quelque chose de majeur est que moi
j'attendais j'appelais de mes voeux est
d'ailleurs françois hollande l'avait
souhaité puis finalement il avait reculé
devant l'obstacle c'est qu'il ya plus de
sortie directe de l'école dans les
grands corps est là pour le coup je te
qu'applaudir parce que penser qu'à 25
ans pour les plus jeunes et des élèves
qui sortent de l'ena on se met à
contrôler
inspectez l'action de fonctionnaires qui
ont 10 20 30 ans d'expérience on a tous
le souvenir de jeunes qui parfois bien
mal malgré eux sont d'une arrogance et
d'une méconnaissance ils font un peu
penser à ce qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
dans le bon sens et à quelques-uns de
centre l'adjudant le documentaire malgré
tout et ça n'est pas un classement de
sortie
c'est à dire une photo un instantané de
80 90 personnes à un moment donné de
leur vie qui doit déterminer si vous
prenez la trajectoire d'une formule 1 ou
si vous prenez la trajectoire d'une
voiture diesel
donc le fait qu'il n'y ait plus d'accès
direct aux grands corps à la sortie de
l'école mais qu'elle était depuis
longtemps dans l'esprit de ceux qui
voulaient réformer l'ena ça va être le
cas et c'est une très bonne chose
je voudrais qu'on regarde à nouveau un
autre extrait parce que on se demande
quand même si cette réforme vraiment
aller jusqu'au bout emmanuel macron fait
des annonces
il ya eu d'autres présidents qui ont
fait des annonces notamment nicolas
sarkozy qui avait parlé de la
suppression du classement de sortie et
c'est bien rappeler dans le film
notamment avec rachida dati ça n'a pas
abouti pour une raison simple une forme
de corporatisme du conseil d'état
regarder
en septembre 2009 nicolas sarkozy fait
passer un décret qui supprime le fameux
classement de sortie mais la riposte
s'organise deux mois plus tard le
conseil d'état se débrouille pour
annuler le texte vous êtes juge et
partie donc ceux convoqués étaient
concernés quand vous avez un décret qui
peut remettre en cause de qui vous êtes
ce que vous êtes
je sais pas s'ils ont été totalement
objectif dans le dans la remise en cause
du décret vie ça c'est mon point de vue
très personnel
alors c'est le point de vue très
personnel de rachida dati mais votre
point de vue christian eckert sur la
réforme qui se dessine est ce qu elle
peut se heurter à des réflexes
corporatistes et est ce que ces réflexes
peuvent sont de nature à empêcher la
réforme
non je crois que je là encore c'est la
force du pouvoir politique sa volonté
qui devra l'emporter il faut que le
président se donne les moyens mois que
sur relativement de la vie de de ce qu'a
dit tout à l'heure des intervenants
disant il faut laisser sa chance à la
réforme mais la réforme ne doit pas se
cantonner à changer le nom et changer la
nature des études elle doit porter sur
l'aval c'est-à-dire les grands corps sa
viande est évoqué je crois qu'on a peu
parlé de la question du recrutement mais
aussi de la question une fois de plus de
l'argent moi je pense que le problème je
crois c'est gasparin d'air qui le
disaient n'est pas que celui de l'ena
mais dans toutes les grandes écoles et
vous avez un problème de démocratisation
du recrutement je les fais maths sup
maths spé
j'ai fait des grandes écoles je viens
d'un milieu très modeste mais c'est une
exception et ça n'est pas en train de
changer
je crois que nous nous n'avons pas
réussi cette transformation
collectivement et je pense que la
question de l'argent de la culture du
milieu est une question sur laquelle on
doit continuer à travailler il ya
quelques éléments qui ont été faits mais
la sélection par l'argent existe encore
ça je connais les frais de scolarité à
sciences po j enseigne
je discute de temps en temps avec les
étudiants et en l'occurrence si on parle
de l'ena la question de l'argent pour
vous il ya sur un central puisque les
élèves sont rémunérés
il y avait dans ce qui se passe oui mais
dans ce qui se passe avant la question
surtout c'est ce qui se passe avant mais
cosa et des prépas de prépa de prépa que
vous faites pendant les vacances etc y
coûtent des sommes fortes et que
évidemment ces gens là réussissent plus
facilement qu'on condamnerait que les
autres c'est bien la question de
l'argent parfois qui se la sélection
nathalie l'oiseau il va y avoir des
embûches
nathalie lozeau faveur des embûches là
dans les prochaines semaines les
prochains mois cette réforme peut ne pas
aboutir
je crois que c'était plutôt avant qu'il
ya eu quelques combats pour éviter que
leur apport thiriez soit véritablement
mis en oeuvre le président c'est décidé
et l'administration de ce point de vue
là et loyal bien sûr qu'il y aura des
relents de corporatisme quand j'avais
changé le concours d'entrée à l'école
nationale d'administration un très haut
fonctionnaire qui hésité à passer le
dossier au niveau politique et dont je
n'arrivais pas vraiment à comprendre sa
réticence avait fini par me dire très
tard un soir au coin du feu mais votre
concours je ne l'aurais pas réussi parce
que souvent c'est dans ces termes on
entend le reproche aussi du nivellement
par le bas on vous dit votre concours là
au contraire il va être trop facile et
on va finalement recruter des gens qui
écoutent et gaspard landser l'adil est
extraordinairement difficile la vraie
question est là je suis pas complètement
d'accord avec christian katz et moins
l'argent que ce que moi j'appelle le
délit d'initié culturel aujourd'hui sont
des enfants de profs qui sont à
l'énergie comme dans toutes les grandes
écoles
hier qui connaissent des filières ils
savent comment apprendre quoi apprendre
pour réussir les concours et c'est là où
on en manque de diversité qui est
véritablement troublant ça vaut pour
toutes les grandes âmes pour truquer un
mot là-dessus il ya ce parc en isère le
manque de diversité vient d'où selon
vous il vient de cette du collège lui
c'est peut-être des écoles comme le dit
et écrit sur la carte et nathalie
l'oiseau qui sont avant l'ena je tâte ya
une petite défense de sciences po même
si les frais seraient arrêtés ont
beaucoup avancé pascal sciences po il ya
une innovation que moi je trouve
formidable qui a été développée depuis
entendre
c'est celle de la création des
conventions d'éducation prioritaire
maintenant 20 ans à l'initiative de
richard descoings il ya des filières de
recrutement qui est dédié aux personnes
issues des milieux les plus populaires
une forme de discrimination positive qui
est extrêmement efficace et aujourd'hui
à l'assemblée nationale il y à des
députés de la majorité présidentielle
qui ont fait sciences po en étant passé
par ces conventions d'éducation
prioritaire si vous aussi vous convient
au fond ce qui est le plus important
dans dans cette réforme c'est pas
tellement ce qui a été annoncé il ya
quelques jours par emmanuel macron mais
ce qui avait déjà été annoncé au mois de
février c'est à dire cette espèce de ces
prépas talents qui vont permettre à des
à des jeunes issus de tous les milieux
de se dire je peux faire l'ena je je je
vais y penser
gaspard ganzer je pense que c'est
essentiel je pense que ya là une grande
partie des français si ce n'est la
quasi-totalité qu'ils soient ignore à
moi c'est à l'état soit se disent qu
évidemment c'est pas pour eux comme il
se le dise de beaucoup d'autres grandes
écoles et ça c'est la responsabilité de
l'éducation nationale de l'enseignement
supérieur de montrer que chacun a sa
chance
permettez moi de rebondir simplement sur
les conventions d'éducation prioritaire
c'est une fausse bonne idée me
semble-t-il je rappellerai d'ailleurs je
pense que neil en vain la science po
plus que de l'ena on accède à l'ena par
les cep
je pense que nathalie l'oiseau ne me
démentira pas non pas vraiment repartir
de zéro je terminerais là dessus
nathalie l'oiseau on se dit pardon de
parler comme certains
d'abord de l'anglicisme legrand risette
qui d'ailleurs un peu prisé des milieux
populiste au passage repartir de zéro
c'est pas une illusion quand on quand on
parle de l'ena écoutez restée crispée
sur des institutions qui ont vieilli ça
ce serait une faute ya une chose dont on
n'a pas parlé parce qu'on ne veut pas
parler de toute la réforme mais à
laquelle j'étais très attaché je suis
très heureuse que de retrouver ça dans
la proposition du président de la
république sait que l'institut du
service public devienne enfin une école
avec des enseignants permanents avec de
la recherche avec une diplomation et pas
simplement une transmission de savoir
faire qui se faisait d'une manière
artisanale avec tout le charme de
l'artisanat mais aussi parfois les
faiblesses il ya quelque chose dans la
qualité de l'enseignement que moi
j'espérais vraiment faire rentrer à
l'ena sa entrera à l'institut du service
public et je lui souhaite le meilleur
merci beaucoup nathalie l'oiseau l'ena
est mort tout bientôt vive l'institut du
service public merci à tous les quatre
je renvoie à votre livre éric en sont
les élites françaises des lumières au
grand confinement aux éditions passées
composé merci à toutes et à tous de nous
avoir suivi et à très bientôt sur public
sénat
[Musique]